for anyone who wants to be a jackass and
say that people don't like this because
there's not enough bang bang action
and it's not mcu familiar
there's a reason people are comparing to
doom because both movies are sci-fi epic
fantasies with a lot more on its mind
than just being a blockbuster film
there's a big ensemble cast no one one
is a superhero movie while the other one
has
supernatural quality good quality you
know a lot of sci-fi elements on both
they're not
one-to-one comparison but i could i
would way more compare those two versus
this in thor the dark world and my point
being is that obviously critics and
audiences can get on board with deep
complex
sci-fi fantasy sweeping epics
now it's really about
will they get on board with this one
well
well
well
i'm going to talk about this once an
official critics consensus is
established here on the website rotten
tomatoes for eternals because yeah i
mean we've been i posted something about
it on the community page and we've
talked a little bit about it off camera
already but now we have a consensus this
can go up and down because there's only
107 reviews factoring in for today
what's today is that 29th and 29th
today's the 29th 10 50 a.m there's 107
reviews and chongqi has like somewhere
between three to 400 reviews yeah so
just to give you an idea of how many
more reviews are gonna be coming in for
this movie okay right now it's sitting
at the mcu's lowest
critical score yes the lowest the mcu
has ever had still fresh but for now 62
and it seems like it could potentially
be the first one to hit
the rotten mark and i want to state this
right up front when it comes to the
superhero movies especially or any
blockbuster film really i always believe
in an audience score or a cinema score i
think the audience's opinion matters way
more than a critic score you might have
seen already where john and i did a
video where we just got out of the
eternal premiere gave our quick thoughts
and uh we felt quite differently about
it one really liked it the other was
like it's okay i guess you know and then
i ended up doing a a deep dive
non-spoiler talking and it's very
different than a lot of other people's
non-spoiler talk that's one thing i'll
credit the video for coin i we debated
extensively about it and i went way more
into depth about the things that i did
like and the things that i didn't like
or that i was you know sort of iffy on
to put it lightly the thing i was most
wrong about
was i didn't expect it to be this
divisive critics i was very much wrong
about that when we talked with people
even coy was saying like it would
probably be in the 70s to 80s and that
was like everyone's who i was speaking
with of where they thought it would land
critically because especially when you
like on the social media reactions which
are usually touting the film up when you
come out of a premiere screening like
most people were so positive even people
who were doing videos on it most people
were so positive i was certain that i
would be like way more in the minority
about my opinion on it and i don't
dislike it to the degree that a lot like
i would still ultimately recommend the
movie i'm just not you know enthusiastic
about it to to say the least but john
how how are you reacting someone who
really liked this movie how are you how
are you reacting to the critical score
so far uh it's been a fun roller coaster
to watch thus far and the biggest thing
to me is that everybody's making this
comparison of oh it's even worse than
thor of the dark world it's the lowest
mcu tomato meter score and there's a lot
of to do that's made out of the tomato
meter there's a lot of debate about what
it's for and how to use it and and what
is the legitimacy i think it's
interesting i'm i'm mostly curious to
see what this is gonna do to the turnout
of audiences to see the movie and the
ultimate audience reception because you
had these initial thoughts of oh this is
gonna be this amazing thing oscar worthy
says kevin feige and now you're seeing
these tomato meter scores and i mean
when you put out your opinion people
were pretty quick to jump on you and be
like no it can't be um and so now that
the you know the movie is actually
starting to get out to more and more and
more people i am validating yeah i was
gonna say how does it feel how does it
feel to be wrong about the little thing
but write about your opinion now man i'm
still right about the fact that majority
are ultimately recommended yeah i i'm
curious about how people are going to
take this because to me this is an
excellent example of the nuance that the
tomato meter can represent whereas like
thor the dark world and i'm not the
first person to point this out even but
thor the dark world if you cruise all
those capsule reviews a lot of people's
opinion is like you know it's kind of
lackluster it's fine whereas if you
cruise the eternals reviews there's a
whole lot of praise then tempered with
you know this is beautiful the cast is
great it's got all this scope and
sweeping ambition however it's a little
emotionally detached and it's a little
hampered by its plotting and stuff like
that and so i feel as though the tomato
score ultimately wherever it lands is
gonna be a might deceptive maybe in
terms of the way people like to go
that's the how good or not percentage
the movie is and i mean i could see this
now dropping into like the high 50s or
something like that or maybe rising
closer to the 70s and that's the big
thing i'm curious about is that yeah we
have at least on the you know critical
tomato meter 200 or more reviews still
set to drop in through the next few
weeks and that's the big thing i am
quite curious about along with how
everyone at marvel must be feeling
because you know they've had big
confidence in this movie but it's got to
have been a different reception than
they were expecting and certainly hoping
for yeah because i went on the community
page and and i was stating some i'm
really looking forward to the debate
around this film that's a big reason why
i'm i encourage everyone to go see it
just make up your own mind a lot of
people have the habit of predetermining
you you can
look at a trailer and go i don't think
i'm gonna like it i think i will like it
but don't get married to that
predetermined opinion always go in with
an open mind and you might be surprised
if anything having lower expectations
with this might actually help you enjoy
the movie instead of going let me see if
i can validate all my negativity towards
it that would never be my goal even if
i'm not fully recommending a film so i
am looking forward to the debate i'm not
looking forward to uh you know comments
i'm not looking forward to the vitriol
i'm not looking forward to the bile and
the and the nastiness i know alone just
putting up this video with the title the
subject that a lot of people won't even
listen to the video they'll downvote
they'll leave a mean comment just
because that's what people do yeah look
at our light year opening bit
gonna have a big red light for any time
sarcasm is in the room
we're not even being sarcastic in this
video
but people will judge it just based off
like i said the title and the subject
and also i think a contributing factor
will be the fact that people associate
my opinion with eternals as a strong
dislike even though i don't believe the
case is a strong dislike i i think i'm
just like
well yeah it seemed like part of what
took you aback was that you didn't have
as strong of any feeling yeah and i've
already done enough talking about my
feelings and opinion on it i do want
this movie to increase in the critical
score and the audience scores simply due
to the fact that i do believe the mcu
while a lot of their films often have a
familiar structure see there's like
story and then there's plot and i
honestly don't think this movie
is completely void of mcu structure i
think there's a lot about it i'm like no
it's it's a kind of a similar structure
to a lot but the plotting the like the
the scene placements and the way the
scenes are are executed overall that's
why you hear a lot of people saying the
words dense i know it's an annoying word
now in the words tense
and why it's different i think the mcu
is more diverse than it's given credit
for personally this is definitely more
different and the way they decide to
tell their
superhero ensemble tale is so
differently executed than you might
initially think when hearing of this
idea and that's a big part of why i'm
like no i want this to go because i want
i want the people at marvel to feel
encouraged to keep taking chances to try
different things instead of doing more
black widows you know that because i
that's the main reason i would recommend
this over black widow even though i i
don't like that movie uh i don't like
black widow i think this is better
simply due to the strength of its
ambitions and what it was ultimately
setting out to do so that's just kind of
where i land with it admittedly there
was a part of me that was a little bit
relieved because it sucks when you're
like oh this movie has a 99 percent and
i am the one person man he doesn't
like i'm always going to be honest but
that can that could be a shitty feeling
yeah absolutely uh so to we see this i'm
like oh thank god i'm not alone um
however i'm not like please suffer yeah
yeah yeah well i i hope that they do see
the divisiveness perhaps as a strength
because division among audiences can be
a good thing in that it gets people
debating and it also shows that yeah you
took a chance so i i do hope that this
does not discourage them at all and it
bums me out to see so many headlines
with just that one sentiment of eternals
is the lowest rated lower than thor the
dark world because at first glance that
implies uh something a lot more simple
and a lot less fair i think to the
overall scope of what the movie's trying
to trying to do well i think with thor
the dark world thor the dark world is
extremely mcu familiar just not executed
well yes this is nowhere near as mcu
familiar yeah and it's really about how
did you handle the different execution
it's like this is lower than it's like
the critic's score is on par with venom
yeah
i bet motherb
you know but you wouldn't watch the
movies and go they're pretty similar
they're on an equal level of quality
no if anything one thing i'm finding is
people are kind of comparing this movie
more to dune absolutely and dune has a
reasonably high audience pretty high
audience score and a pretty high critic
score
and that movie is i think exceptionally
more heady and more dense way more it's
much more uh
difficult to i don't say difficult but
you definitely gotta focus more to
understand the details and and even just
the plot you gotta focus up way more
so for anyone who wants to be a jackass
and say that people don't like this
because there's not enough bang bang
action and it's not mcu familiar there's
a reason people are comparing to doom
because both movies are sci-fi epic
fantasies with a lot more on its mind
than just being a blockbuster film
there's a big ensemble cast no one one
is a superhero movie while the other one
has supernatural quality good quality
you know a lot of sci-fi elements on
both with timothy chapman's character
there's a bit of a superhero-esque
nature to it they're not
one-to-one comparison but i would way
more compare those two versus this in
thor the dark world yeah and my point
being is that obviously critics and
audiences can get on board with deep
complex sci-fi fantasy sweeping epics
now it's really about
will they get on board with this one
absolutely that's the question i think i
ended up great you did that's probably
the smartest
i'm gonna play this video backwards
so you could start on your best point
anyway where do you guys think this will
ultimately end up being do you think
it'll end up being rotten do you think
this is gonna affect the box office do
you think the audience score will be
higher than the critic score it usually
is but sometimes it's not leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell hit that like button
leave the burp
catch you guys soon
[Music]
you